hello and welcome to the new odd review
a source for everything anime and manga
and i have to apologize once again
because we're here for more black clove
although that's not what i'm apologizing
for
black clover is pretty fantastic but we
are currently tackling the reincarnation
arc and after reaching chapter 182 this
time around i
i have to call it quits once again
because there is so much to talk about
and we will definitely finish it next
week i've been told that i'm probably
about
two-thirds of the way through now and
for some reference i stopped when astor
and the black bulls arrived at the
capital to reunite with yami
and others because to me when the army's
around it doesn't really matter who else
is there and before we get into this
action patch and anakinry don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to the
new world review if you want to see more
black clover style stuff
if you forget then yami will never
forgive you and even worse charmy
i'll never forgive you either but we
begin this part of the ark in a very
appropriate place with astor and yuna
returning to their village to defend it
from the elven menace i enjoyed this a
lot because this is the first time that
we've had this like tangible marker of
progression this is the place where we
started the series and at the time
master was a useless [ __ ] and now at
this point in the series we've returned
to this same location
except asta is now a useful [ __ ] and
you know has pointy ears
everyone's progressed in some way or
another and the villagers get to witness
this they get to see
asta further along on his journey than
really any one of them would have
believed he'd get
because he is surely the most impressive
one here you know is yoona so they were
all expecting him to be
like glorious but astor was an utter
failure but now he's proving himself to
the people who knew him best and it was
just such a satisfying scene to read
after having gone through
i guess everything in black clover to
date also astor gets a new toy or a new
form of toyota is it a new sword or is
it like
i don't know yet this cloverclad sword
that can definitely apparently break the
reincarnation spell which he was
previously unable to do
although my first thought is why didn't
you break the spell on yuno right then
and there
there is still an elf on that shelf of a
boy and i think that that could be a
grand threat in the future and i do get
that he's more powerful in this form
i think i don't actually know that but
you know is a boss anyway so why not
rid ourselves of this elvish compromise
in any case we didn't do that but it's a
wonderful part of the story to read
regardless after which we arrive at a
slightly more intense confrontation with
luck and there are lots of things i like
about this one of which is that we get
to call back to the whole flashback with
his mother and that pays off so nicely
because we've now spent a ton of time
with him it's much easier to feel the
whole luck is our friend thing when
asked her says it rather than when it
originally happened way back in the
second arc where astor said it like
five minutes after meeting lock but
there was also this really heartwarming
panel of his mother looking on as luck
tells her that he has to go back and
that was oh that was very sweet a nice
way to expand his story and even
potentially bring some closure to the
character because his mother looks
incredibly proud of him and seemingly
for all of the right reasons this time
also my favorite spell in the series
destiny cat got to be featured a bit
more and it came equipped with the
limitations i was seeking from that
whole witch arc
as it turns out it is indeed a massive
mana drain on vanessa as it should be
but it's still an incredibly ridiculous
utility kitty which when implemented as
part of a team is absolutely invaluable
i love it it was also very interesting
in exactly how it was used because
fighting against luck another black ball
member the cap pretty much negated
everything and made it so that no one
could hurt anyone else which is a very
tricksy situation to find yourself in as
is this whole
elf soul thing in fact this luck
situation has sown a pretty big seed for
potential tragedy with his elf soul
sort of repenting towards its defeat and
saying stuff like i
wanted to make friends with humans too
humans like you
which was painful because it makes me
think that i'm going to feel pretty damn
terrible for elves in general during the
sock or after the sock like they were
much more victims than antagonists
although with that said that doesn't
really show up
anywhere else in what i've read so far
and the up souls still seem rather
dickish plenty of time left though and
we've got some more reincarnation in
this reincarnation arc as well right
towards the end of what i read we had
both fauna and veto make an appearance
apparently in 15 year old bodies i'm
guessing there were clones of the human
bodies although i don't know for sure
but does this mean that we now have
two fauna running around i guess finale
if you will
for pluralization black love goes to
some weird places with bodies and
personalities and just wondering who is
who or who isn't who which speaking of i
now know who not licht is
it's part tree of course country i
i'm not going to lie i still have no
idea who that is it's definitely
possible that i miss something because
my experience of the elves feels very
very muddled and like i have no real
grounding with any of them so i'm sorry
if that's something i've overlooked and
i'm even more sorry for bringing it up
if it's something i'm not meant to know
yet look i'm just i'm just sorry but at
the very least we got
some more william time with a very sad
sort of flashback and a better
explanation as to why he decided to let
not licked patri and julius fight it out
and after experiencing those pages i do
actually feel for his situation quite a
bit more it's a massive moral quandary
like what are you supposed to do when
you're infinitely loyal to one party
and profoundly empathize with another so
it was quite sad to hear that he had
passed into what i think was called
endlessly but at the same time there's a
lot of room to bring him back as well
because after the discovery of astor's
reincarnation breaker it's feeling more
and more like we'll just take these
people back one by one
and in the end if not licked is defeated
then surely that body just returns to
william
i think no i don't know i actually don't
know at all i have no idea however it
was rather bittersweet to learn that
even this super evil not like delph did
consider william to be a true friend
their only human friend which once again
opens up the potential gates of empathy
for even this seemingly
unrecoverable character in reincarnation
in some form or another continues to be
a very strong theme of this arc even
without elvish madness because rather
sally and the other one well they also
managed to bring their souls back into
their bodies more specifically because
of rades which i was not expecting at
all i thought they were just done and
dusted goodbye weird ass trio but
instead it's like hello again weird ass
trio and i dare say it's nice to see
them again
because now that they're temporary
allies they're actually kind of fun to
be around radas in particular seems to
do very well with comic elements
alongside asda and i do
have a soft spot for antagonist flipping
sides it's also good to have another
spatial magic user on this side in
finral stead because that seems pretty
damn essential the more i read of the
series the more i get the impression
that spatial magic is wildly overpowered
and probably the most useful utility one
can really have as part of a team with
that said i am getting a bit worried
that nobody in this arc seems to be
capable of dying i mean i think there
are actually a few nobles who are sorted
but nobody cares about them we're
talking about named characters which i
suppose make sense it's the
reincarnation
arc not the kill everyone arc but it
makes me more nervous that tarbata is
going to go back on the whole wizard
king killing idea that doesn't matter
for now though because let's talk about
noel holy crap this situation is a huge
part of why i had to stop because her
involvement is probably my favorite part
of the circle as far it was great to see
her fight for and alongside her siblings
specifically nozzle who had some
fantastic words
specifically stuff like not you noel
you're a royal you're coming with me to
defend the castle and also the fact that
he ended up apologizing to her which is
that's pretty well and to top it all off
noelle is now
incredible having conjured that water
valkyrie armor which while she does not
possess her mother's magic finity still
evokes her almost entirely and turns
noelle into a fully fledged combatant
with this spell surely she does not sit
on the sidelines anymore and only get
tapped to support and i also very much
enjoyed the explanation for how noel can
access something like this which i think
was something along the lines of well
royals are born with phenomenal magic
but they never bother to train it
meanwhile commoners are born with feeble
magic but train heavily to make it
potent and then there's noel who was
born with absurd magic
and trained it thus catapulting her into
a whole new sphere of magical
shenanigany it shows her hard work
paying off and this situation was also
perfectly sculpted to noel because their
elvish opponent was using a brand of
magic that disturbs the minor control of
others which is very interesting because
that's
kind of noel's entire problem all her
life she has been operating under these
conditions of terrible
terrible mana control so her siblings
got a taste of what it was like to be
noel and they were
completely useless for the most part
meanwhile noel who is very much
experienced under these conditions rose
to the occasions and in a stroke of
brilliance even concocted a plan to
drown a fool and it didn't work in the
end but it was still a fantastic idea
and while the whole thing was just
glorious it actually pairs very well
alongside astor and yuno's return to
their village in the same way that they
got to go home and protect their roots
noel also experienced something of a
homecoming and stood up to protect the
house of silva which i guess is probably
just referred to as house silver and
that idea of protecting home is
obviously a huge motif in this section
because everyone's place of safety is
under attack
and while it's not quite as potent as
noel's seen we do have a similar
situation happening with the crimson
lions and leopold defending his squad
from an
elf which does lead us to the fantastic
return of fuego leon i have been waiting
for this man to show up for an awfully
long time now and he did not disappoint
in fact he's better than ever because he
has taken command of fauna's
well one of the fauna's salamander
spirits which yeah he is at this point
in time the absolutely perfect vessel
for that and i cannot wait to see him
destroy some fools
on behalf of his sister meanwhile
everywhere else everyone is playing out
their own fated individual conflicts
like yami facing off against charlotte
which doesn't play out to a conclusion
also finral versus langris but there's a
wide breadth of conflict to play with
which only works so well because tarbata
has slowly but surely built up these
little relationships which sometimes yes
that building is clunky and weird and
doesn't quite fit into the arc specific
situations but it does pay off in
something like this because we could
have had a much more standard shonen
approach where certain protagonists each
need to face off against a random enemy
where you don't necessarily care but i
find myself carrying quite a bit here
because even if the elves have taken
over certain bodies that character
dynamic is still sort of in play i mean
even the purple orca captain
dude got some time to himself and i
honestly never thought we'd see him
again so all of these characters are
beginning to pay off in some way or
another and that is exciting because we
still have a fair few more to go this
arc is anything but over and right now
i'm just being taunted with the thought
of one of the last things i've currently
seen which was the opening of what i
think was called the shadow palace a
very ominous dimensional construct
hidden or sealed within the clover
kingdom which also delivers our first
calamity scale event in black clover
which is that seemingly the idea is to
put a stone in a thing and sacrifice all
of the human souls in elf commented
bodies and that's
that's pretty bad but also fun because
it does at least artificially raise the
stakes of the ark to a level we've not
previously seen with black clover and
look it's a very one piece standard
device actually in every mega rock there
is always this
localized apocalypse that we need to
stop in addition to actually defeating
the ultimate antagonist
and they're great because they create
chaos and also they give characters who
have no business fighting the main
antagonist something to in the meantime
you know they're charged with stopping
the catastrophe
but i suppose we'll see how things play
out in any case i'm pretty excited to
conclude the reincarnation arc which i
promise we will do
next week but that pretty much does it
for this blind review of part 2 of the
reincarnation arc and what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
small black clover content then please
to go and check out some of my other
videos or even subscribe to the channel
for very maybe black clover goodness
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review and i'll see you next time